the reason why I asked the question is
religion inherently conservative
progressive or revolutionary is because
I think especially among our European
friends there is this tendency to view
American religion as peculiarly
conservative and that is in large part
because of the publicity that the
Christian Right began achieving starting
in the late 1970s with people like Pat
Robertson and Jerry Falwell and the
important role and it was an important
role that religious conservatives played
in elective ronald reagan in nineteen
eighty and so i think it's very
important to look back at the trajectory
of religion and it's again i emphasize
evangelical religion only because its
associated so much with conservatism
with political conservatism now to say
that the history is quite different than
that if you look at our anti-slavery
movement the great stain on american
life was racism and slavery and it's a
struggle we have had for from the very
beginning of our country and something
with which we still struggle i argue
that in some ways we have at least the
advantage over other nations that we've
been at this problem longer than most
society is because we committed this
original sin and I think we struggle
with it more than most societies but it
is our original sin and when you go back
and look at who mobilized people against
slavery who are the first people to come
along in our politics and say this is
morally wrong not that we should
compromise with it not that maybe we
should extinguish it gradually but we
must repeal this the anti-slavery
movement came in significant part out of
the evangelical movement in America out
of the conversion of evangelicals that
the rise of evangelicals and a lot of
individual conversions in the 1820s and
1830s these evangelical movement then
became linked and this is particularly
the evangelical movement in the north
and I think an understanding American
religion it's always important to
understand the split between the North
and South that created caused the Civil
War
in our country the same evangelicals
were in favor of ending imprisonment for
death they were in favor of creating
asylums for the mentally ill instead of
mistreating the mentally ill they were
in favor of establishing a rigorous
public school system so to a very large
degree the evangelicals were the
progressives in American politics jumped
forward to what we call our progressive
era presidents Teddy Roosevelt and
Woodrow Wilson whom Rob reference the a
lot of the people who became partisans
in the progressive movement were people
who went into America's slums in the
1880s and 1890s people like Jane Addams
for religious reasons and they were
trying to help people one on one on one
and they became progressive because they
over time while they honored the one on
one work they were doing they also
realized that only structural change in
the society in the economy would
actually lift folks up jump further
still to our civil rights movement um
the if you look at all of the surveys in
the following is a defensible statement
that african-americans are the most
religious people in America there are
other people who are religious but if
you take their many many non-african
Americans who are very religious but the
african-american community is very
religious if you think about the
preaching of Martin Luther King the
reason why I think he was a successful
leader beyond a genius for tactics in
the way in which non-violence played so
brilliantly into a media age to see
innocent demonstrators who are being
nonviolent beaten by white policemen
energized the country but I think at a
theoretical level the reason he
converted people if I may use that word
was his fluency with the two key
religious documents in the United States
one being the Bible and the other being
our Declaration of Independence the
other thing I want to close
is something that I've been talking
about a lot in relation to my book I
really believe that we Americans are
under stating to ourselves the
importance of our own communitarian
tradition the side of ourselves it is
not radically individualistic that is
not Clint Eastwood I think that
Americans actually are very confusing to
ourselves as well as to you I mean we
produce movies like it's a wonderful
life which some of you may have seen the
great Jimmy Stewart Christmas movie
that's all about community and we
produce Dirty Harry we produce writers
like John Steinbeck which is all about
social justice and community and we
produce writers like Jack Kerouac which
is all about individualism and
individual adventure and so we are
confusing people and yet and that but I
think that right now our tendency is to
focus for more on individualism and
losing our gift for community so what I
want to close on is to link two very
unlikely characters for you I want to
link Bruce Springsteen with john
winthrop one of the Puritan founders of
America now you may ask what do bruce
springsteen and john winthrop have could
possibly have in common how much how
many people here are actually fans of
Springsteen I've always wondered if it's
a peculiarly American taste now well
that's very good that's a that's a
pretty good percentage how many people
know who Bruce Springsteen is let's try
that okay the I the so who's my Puritan
my puritanism man called John Winthrop
who many of you remember those of you
who are older remember Ronald Reagan
always referring to the United States as
a shining city on a hill that came from
a sermon by john winthrop one of the
founders early governor of Massachusetts
a sermon he gave in 1630 called a model
of Christian charity
I just want to share one line from that
sermon he said we must delight in each
other make others conditions our own
rejoice together mourn together labor
and suffer together always having before
our eyes our community as members of the
same body sounds something straight out
of st. Paul actually we are all part of
one another now that's the Puritan what
a Springsteen have to do with this for
those of you who are true fans that
handful of you you will know that one of
his most the new popular hit that he has
put out as part of his new album you
will now hear it on the Obama campaign
he has started playing this at his
rallies and the refrain of the song is
wherever this flag is flown he's talking
about the American flag wherever this
flag is flown we take care of our own
and I do believe there is a trajectory
from john winthrop to Bruce Springsteen
and I do believe that is communitarian
spirit is one of the very best things
about us that we ought to talk about it
more but even more we order practice it
more and I want to close where I started
to thank the Nexus Institute what I sort
of really appreciate about what Rob does
and what I appreciate that all you would
come out and have a conversation like
this is what I said at the beginning
that if we care about preserving
societies that value freedom equality
community we're not going to preserve
those societies if we don't think about
the meaning of those things but if we
don't think about where they came from
if we don't root them in something more
than our own personal preferences
because you know our personal
preferences alone these are fundamental
principles that we want a whole society
to live by and I want to salute you all
for putting up with me for all this time
and for caring enough or having teachers
who care enough that you are willing to
engage in this kind of discussion
and it's a dangerous invitation but if
any of you are ever in the United States
please give me a call thank you very
very much